Let's say there's
some company A here.
And let's think about what
its stock might be doing.
Let's say this is just
over the course of the day.
Let's say its stock is just
trading right over here.
So as we go through the day,
it's price naturally changes.
But then right over here-- let's
say this is within the day,
maybe this is happening
at 10AM Eastern
Time-- an announcement comes
out that B intends to acquire A.
I don't know, let's
say that right now A
is trading at $5 a share,
but a press release comes out
that B intends to
acquire A at $10 a share.
So you can imagine--
And they say
they're going to
do it with cash.
And we'll talk in
future videos about how
it becomes a little bit
more involved if they're
going to be doing it
with their own shares,
but they intend to
do it with cash.
So if they're able to
acquire A, everyone
who owns a share of company
A will get $10 for it,
and those shares
will go to company
B. Company B will own
company A all of a sudden.
So what do you
think would happen
to the stock of company A?
We know that B intends to
buy it for $10 a share.
Well, you could imagine
if everyone thought
that this is definitely
going to happen,
that anyone who holds the
stock is going to get $10.
You could imagine that the stock
would just gap up immediately
to something close
to $10 a share.
And then not even
trade much around it,
because they know what
they're going to get for it.
So this is if you knew that
this merger or this acquisition
was going to happen.
The reality is, is
that you don't always
know just from
this press release
that B definitely
will acquire A. Maybe
they have to get approval
from government bodies
to make sure that they aren't
getting a monopoly here.
Maybe they still have to get
the funding from some bank,
they still have to
get a loan in order
to be able to do this deal.
Maybe something else happens.
Maybe there's another bidder
who wants to acquire A
and they're willing to pay more.
So you don't know
exactly what's going
to happen in this situation.
So you don't know for sure
this is going to happen.
So what does normally
happen is that instead
of going all the way up, it
goes someplace in-between.
So the reality, instead
of jumping from $5 to $10,
it might jump from, I
don't know, $5 to $8,
and maybe it trades around here.
You might say, well,
why does it trade at $8?
And it would trade
at $8-- so notice,
if there was 100% chance it
would trade all the way to $10,
right, because that's what
stock A would be worth now,
because B is going to pay that.
But if it trades at $8
essentially the market
is saying that we're
going to give you 3/5.
From $5 to $8 is $3.
So it's giving you 3/5
of the total jump that it
could have if it
was 100% chance.
Or another way to say it
is, is that the market
is saying that there
is a 60% percent
chance that this
merger will go through.
Anyone who thinks that
there's more than a 60%
chance-- if they do this
over a bunch of securities,
so that all the probabilities
kind of work out eventually--
they should buy this security.
Because they could buy
at $8, and they think
it really should be worth $10.
Anyone who thinks that, no way
that this acquisition is going
to happen, B isn't going
to get the financing
or the regulatory
authorities aren't going
to allow B to do this, then
they should short the stock
when it goes up here.
Because if the
acquisition falls through,
then the stock is going
to go back down here.
It's going to go back
down to the $5 range
before the announcement.
And so people, and
especially hedge funds,
who act in this way
based on their thinking
that the merger is
more likely to occur
or less likely to occur--
based on their research,
or maybe they have some
quantitative models,
information other people don't
have that might be legal
or might be otherwise--
they would place these bets.
The people who think that
the merger will happen,
will buy expecting
it to go to $10.
The people who think it
won't, they will short,
expecting it to go to $5.
And this strategy of playing
the probabilities of a merger
happening, this is
called merger arbitrage.
Merger arb, sometimes
called for short.
And it's arbitrage
because someone
who feels like they know the
merger is going to happen,
they can buy something
for $8 and then sell.
Or they could buy
something for $8
that is going to be worth $10.
They can sell it for
$10 at some future date
when B acquires a company.
Or, if they know the merger
isn't going to happen,
they can short it for $8
and then buy it back for $5.
Once again, kind of doing
an arbitrage on a price
differential.
They think something
that's worth $5
is trading at $8
on the down side.
On the upside, they think
something that's trading at $8
is worth $10.